[Musica]
nel 2000 la gazzetta dello sport fa un
censimento tra i suoi lettori chiede chi
siano i dieci ciclisti più importanti
nella storia dello sport ovviamente al
primo posto c'è coppi a secondo merz al
terzo bartali ma scendendo al decimo e
ultimo posto su un nome non conosciuto
da tutti
luigi malabrocca la maglia nera del giro
d'italia luigi malabrocca nasce nel 1920
e l'ultimo di sette fratelli gialli e un
destino nasce ultimo ama la bicicletta è
uno che può correre veloce e uno che
potrebbe vincere anzi all'inizio della
sua carriera vince delle gare però
gareggia negli anni di coppi bartali
fiorenzo magni loro sono delle superstar
e quindi lui è uno di quelli che può
arrivare nei primi dieci posti nel 1946
fa il suo primo giro d'italia parte bene
a un certo punto buca cade e arriva
ultimo la cosa non li fa molto piacere e
in albergo
passa la notte rigirandosi nel letto
a un certo punto alle 5 del mattino
bussano alla porta apre la porta e trova
un contadino con con dell'insalata
prendi lui subito non capisce non
capisce che è un'italia che sta con i
perdenti
il contadino se ne va e ne pare un altro
lui si affaccia e vede una figlia di
persone ognuno riporta qualcosa qualcosa
da mangiare qualcosa da leggere dei
vestiti in fondo alla fine c1 con un
agnello in braccio
beh si avvicina beh io sono l'ultimo di
dieci fratelli beh mai avuto nulla
farò come ti prendi me beh beh va beh
non è male essere l'ultimo sì perché
quel giro d'italia
i soldi li prendevano solo i primi tre
tutti gli altri non guadagnano e allora
malabrocca a un lampo di genio decide di
arrivare ultimo nasce così la maglia
nera del giro d'italia è un'italia
particolare è un'italia del dopoguerra è
divisa da una parte ci sono i
democristiani
dall'altra parte ci sono i comunisti
trieste spaccata in due da una parte gli
slavi dall'altra e filo americane per
farvi capire in che epoca siamo vi leggo
un pezzo di cronaca proprio del corriere
di allora il gruppo del giro si sta
avvicinando alla città quando vicino
pieris vicino a trieste
alcuni sostenitori di tito sbarrano al
passaggio con sassi e filo spinato dalla
collina volano sassi molti corridori
scappano ausenda viene colpito la spalla
marangoni cade colpito in testa bartali
si nasconde sotto la 1100 partono anche
a sparare malabrocca scrive la moglie
linfa mia non ti preoccupare per quel
che leggi al primo sasso
io ero già giu nel fosso manco bartali è
stato veloce come me ci avevo un solo
pensiero
altro che sono altro che soldi voglio le
mie talpe io io voglio tornare da te io
qui ci lascia la pelle sentivo un dolore
nel petto e nel fondo della scheda ma io
zitto zitto
poi quando si è calmato tutto ho capito
il dolore erano i rovi del fossato ne
avevo anche uno piantato nel culo non è
idea dopo salire sulla bicicletta
la maglia nera malabrocca diventava una
figura politica
gli ultimi si riconoscono in lui
mentre lui che regia spesso vede delle
scritte sui muri
maglia nera vinci per noi maglia nera la
rivoluzione proletaria farà con te un
giorno sta pedalando a piediluco tra
roma e perugia e viene fermato i tifosi
invadono la strada lo fermano le dico lo
vieni con noi viene a mangiare dato che
lui deve arrivare ultimo
non si tira indietro va subito a
mangiare salame pecorino vino salame
pecorino vinu vinu vinu vinu colpo il
pecorino vino sono tre non può arrivare
in ritardo
se finisce oltre il tempo regolamentare
viene squalificato allora certo punto si
mette ancora del pecorino in tasca
ringrazia e parte e colpito mentre
mangiavano le hanno raccontato questa
storia di questi contadini che fanno
fatica arrivare alla fine del mese lui è
grato sale sarà il sua bicicletta inizia
a pedalare loro lo accompagnano lo
spingono ricordati di noi ricordati di
noi e lui mentre pedala mette la mano in
tasca per cercare gli occhialini e trova
del denaro quei contadini che non
riescono ad arrivare alla fine del mese
hanno voluto dare del denaro all'uomo
che li rappresenta quell'anno malabrocca
arriva ultimo diventa la maglia nera del
giro d'italia e grazie a tutti i regali
che ha ricevuto cresce a portare a casa
60 mila lire calcolate che lo stipendio
allora per l'operaio annuale era
diecimila lire linee porta 60.000 è
chiaramente un affare decide di rifarlo
anche l'anno dopo 80 mila lire
essendo anche un esperto antesignano del
marketing l'anno dopo invece non lo fa
lo farà il quarto anno ormai è un eroe
il quartetto c'entra lo canta c'è un
concorso chi sarà la maglia nera
quest'anno
lui è ormai pronto pronto pedalare e
quando tutti gli altri scappano lui si
muove lentamente ma c'è un ma fiorenzo
magni altro ciclista il terzo dopo
bartel e coppi
a un incidente non può più gareggiare
allora la squadra decide di chiamare un
altro ciclista carollo piccolo un po
storto stempiato assolutamente incapace
di vincere lui è un dilettante venne
sbalzato dal suo ruolo di dilettante
professionista lì in un colpo solo
quando gli altri corrono lui arranca
arranca arranca lui è la vera maglia
nera del giro d'italia ma la propria
capisce subito il rischio e quindi
quell'anno abbiamo due giri d'italia
coppi e bartali che cercano di vincere e
malabrocca carollo che cercano di
arrivare ultimi parte qualsiasi tipo di
trucco vale tutto cioè venne raccontato
di carollo che si mette a giocare a
carte con i tifosi mentre malabrocca
scappa malabrocca si nasconde dentro la
tasca di un contadino che racconta che
apre lo trova lì e richiede che ci fai
tu io il giro d'italia e tu ci sono
fotografie dove malabrocca è prima con
gli amici della sposa e poi coi parenti
dello sposo sono sempre lì a cercare di
ritardare il più possibile però sempre
stando nei tempi perché se oltrepassano
i tempi vengono squalificati ci sono
anche di momenti epici nella tappa
quella famosa quella per cui coppi fa la
grande fuga sestriere pinerolo e fa
quella per cui viene chiamata un uomo
solo al comando ma la brocca sta
pedalando anche lui addietro carollo sta
pedalando però a un certo punto gli si
rompe una forcella kahn dopo più
pedalare la vice rotta
il gioco è finito vede per fortuna un
pezzo di legno una scopa rompe la scopre
la mette al posto della forcella e
riparte a pedalare tra gli applausi del
pubblico by malabrocca va in maglia nera
lui pedala pedala pedala 50 metri crack
è finito
è stato bello ma è finito tutto
il pubblico è ammutolito tutti cercherò
di non guardarlo negli occhi e non vedo
che c'è un bambino con la mano alzata
che li dice ehi ma la haye ma la vuoi la
bici di mia mamma eva la brocca la
prende e inizia a pedalare 162 km con la
bici della mamma era troppo tardi
questa volta non arrivato nei tempi
regolamentari viene squalificato
quell'anno la maglia nera e carollo
malabrocca in un'intervista racconta che
lui il ciclismo l'ha capita in un
episodio ben preciso era vicino bergamo
stavano pedalando pioveva non c'erano le
strade asfaltate di adesso c'era fango e
loro arrancavano faticosamente rlo lui e
ausenda il suo amico stavano pedalando
pedalando gli occhialini coperti di
fango non vedono nulla quando sotto la
pioggia sulla destra vedono una casa
il fumo che esce dal camino allora si
ferma non ce la fanno più
si fermano bussano alla porta apre un
bambino e riconosce gli occhi di
malabrocca malabrocca aveva gli occhi un
po a mandorla forma come i cinesi
infatti veniva chiamato il cinese corre
subito dal padre malabrocca un
personaggio famoso papà papà c'è la
maglia leira il pater apre subito la
porta fa entrare malabrocca il suo
compagno ausenda loro entrano c'è un bel
caldo loro piene di fango chiedono scusa
ma la prego prego entra
padre due figli la mamma in piedi e una
nonna vicino al caminetto mangiano la
polenta offrono subite due ciclisti la
polenta che si mettono subito a mangiare
la nonna dopo un po di silenzio
guarda i due ciclisti e gli chiede ma
cosa state facendo è usa end a
rispondere il giro d'italia
mangia ancora un po ma come
ma come in bicicletta ma non la mangio
ancora un po e poi ma non era meglio
farlo in treno
[Applauso]